au lieu de laisser les entreprises les
entrepreneurs allait se démerder a
essayé de faire avancer de leur dossier
à 5,6 en droit c'est guy qui va être en
charge de tout ça donc ils vont avoir je
suis une personne à qui parler et qui va
parler avec les ministères concernés
aidez guy leblanc va nous parler nous ce
soir c'est le pdg d'investissement
québec bonsoir monsieur leblanc bonsoir
en studio alors vous aurez une courbe de
charge sur les épaules parce qu'un
investissement québec va doubler de
taille à partir de maintenant si j'ai
bien compris en quoi ce serait plus
efficace
en fait c'est un mandat élargi qu'on lui
confie et on nous donne des outils
additionnels et de créer qui va se
joindre à nous le centre de recherche
industrielle du québec
il ya également des employés du
ministère d'économie d'innovation en
région que se joignent à nous alors ça
va favoriser l'accompagnement des
entreprises et donc on va au fréon
mettre un point central pour offrir à la
fois l'accompagnement et le financement
aux entreprises
il ya également export québec qui voyait
se joindre à nous exactement le cri que
le centre de recherche industrielle donc
quand on met tout cela ensemble est ce
qu'on y trouve des synergies comment on
peut qualifier
en fait notre modèle on a restructuré
investissement québec et notre modeste
et investissement québec régional va
travailler donc avec les entreprises
pour favoriser l'accompagnement avec le
cric de financement avec les métiers
d'investissement québec et également on
va chercher à augmenter la productivité
donc par des investissements
d'innovation pour l'automatisation des
entreprises mais aussi pour la
transformation numérique mais dans la
grande restructuration d'investissement
québec qui double de taille toutes les
expertises qu'on connaît qu'on
connaissait et qu'on connaît dans les
différentes entités vont demeurer un
investissement québec
les expertises que i investissement
québec faisait va continuer à le faire
parce qu'il le faisait très bien les au
niveau du développement régional sauf
qu'on lui donne des moyens additionnels
avec justement l'accompagnement qui est
absolument clé pour le développement
régional et pour prendre plus de risques
pour prendre également plus de risques
alors dans la chaîne des capitaux on
nous a donné un positionnement très
claire de pallier aux carences de cette
chaîne des capitaux par exemple soit
yard exemple en démarrage
une entreprise en démarrage c'est pas
nécessairement la caisse de dépôt ou la
fonctionnalité qui va les trouver
ça va être en terme technique des
céréales des séries b ça va se faire
avec investissement québec ou des fonds
d'investissement dans lesquels on
investit déjà pour le capital de
croissance parfois l'offre du marché ce
n'est pas suffisant parce que le niveau
de risque commence à être un peu trop
élevé en fonction des demandes qui sont
faites pour accélérer la croissance des
entreprises
on va également investir et dans les
situations plus difficiles vous avez vu
dans le contexte de ce tonneau et par
exemple où on n'a pas hésité à prendre
position
oui et à sauver les emplois dans le nord
du québec tenait jusqu'à quel point on
doit prendre des risques parce que là
vous nommer ses toiles oui il ya orbite
il ya nemaska il ya beaucoup d' entités
dans lesquelles le gouvernement du
québec investissement québec ont investi
de l'argent public et là on voit des
centaines de millions de dollars
disparaître disparaître c'est peut-être
prématuré de parler ça c'est davantage
je vais dans le domaine prendrait de
nemaska où de ce tournoi ont des
entreprises qui sont en restructuration
se demande jusqu'à quel point
l'investissement d'investissement québec
aura encore là vous avez tout à fait
raison ce sont des entreprises sont en
restructuration dans quatre tournois des
prix du diamant ont chuté des experts
prévoient que d'ici deux ans les prix
vont remonter et à ce moment-là ça
coûtait moins cher d'investir de garder
ce tournoi ouvert que de faire ce qu'ils
faisaient de termes anglais mais un mode
bling et de simplement garder
de fermer et de garder sur le côté de
temps que le marché repli donc il faut
faire ce type d'investissement il faut
oser même si un risque quand même des
chèques ou en tout cas de difficultés
ces demandes qu'on nous a donnée de
regarder ça prend un plan match si
j'obtiens match tient la route
il faut que ça soit c'est un autre
mandat c'est pas de ramasser les canards
boiteux puis d'essayer de garder sur
respirateur artificiel
certains matches ça prend une bonne
équipe de direction est et il va même si
le marché est hésitant à suivre
et comment on fait un suivi comment
mesure vos résultats
nos résultats ça va être le mandat qu'on
nous a donné c'est davantage en termes
d'investissements pour augmenter la
productivité des entreprises c'est
davantage pour des exportations et c'est
également l'attraction d'investissements
étrangers dans les secteurs ciblés par
par le gouvernement donc est ce qu'un
engagement de rendement on a un plancher
avant contre x qui est le coût des fonds
du gouvernement alors aujourd'hui c'est
aux alentours des 2 2 points 1 % le
plancher qu'on doit rencontrer c'est ce
2 2 points pour ça on n'est pas
allergique au rendement si on doit faire
plus si on peut faire plus de rendement
on va en faire davantage
on a des investissements en capital de
risque par exemple dans de très très
belles sociétés on est on est investi
dans des liquides québécoise que ce soit
coveo que ce soit l'aï dit nous sommes
avec eux dans ce projet mais on était
les premiers à investir dans ce projet
ou parmi les premiers à investir et on
est toujours présent jeu est donc
l'objectif c'est d'investir d'investir
plus et de ne pas faire concurrence aux
banques aux institutions financières qui
font du finances c'est ce qu'on
reprochait sma québec d'agir dans penser
d'agir un peu comme une banque ce qu'on
veut faire c'est à la fois de continuer
de développement régional mais aussi de
prendre des participations dans des
sociétés et d'être complémentaire à
l'achat
des capitaux d'où on à investissement
québec régionales on à investissement
québec international pour les
exportations et aussi ces bi
directionnelle pour l'attraction
d'investissements étrangers et aussi
l'attraction de talent on va travailler
avec montréal international québec
international du ministère des relations
internationales et tous les partenaires
il va y avoir meilleure cohésion sur le
marché international pour attirer et le
talent et désinvestit bien on va
continuer de vous suivre monsieur
leblanc merci beaucoup merci